ashhadu an la ilaha illa ma who a little
bit about the broad before we meet him
with your neighbors Thank You Stan we
got Dagestan in the house what was it
about Islam that had you accepting the
simplicity what was it about Islam - had
you accepted what was your former well
I'll tell you the truth I was serving in
the US military
well you guys fight man who's trying to
stay we trying to stay out of fight good
to mention this so he's you miss to
certainty what was it about Islam that
has you accepting the simplicity the
same pathology of who God is and I
believe that you know the concept of God
should be very simple you know for
everyone to understand not something to
accomplish so you know again there's a
lot of stuff you know the scientific
facts the simplicity
the clarity in the Koran you know when
you read and how everything just seems
to make sense
you know more than anything else I've
seen so certain things you must believe
in are the articles of faith right to
believe that there is a God to believe
in angels to believe in prophets and
messengers to believe in scriptures to
believe in the day of judgment the day
of resurrection and to believe in a
father or the decree that everything is
already and decreed by Allah span over
time and there's certain things that
pertain to action that you must do one
is to utter the Shahada which we are
about to do and there is something
called Salah prayer did you do that five
times a day and there's something called
charity you do that once a year fasting
in Ramadan and then there's something
called had these are the main things you
need to know everything else 80 90
percent of your son is very simple and
very basic you just need to be a good
person what would you what advice would
you give for other people out there who
are struggling with all the hype you
know all the negative press right but
they're listening to us
and they really gravitate towards this
hearing use recite Quran and the concept
of God what device and you went to a lot
of these things what advice would you
have fun simplest thing is just you know
I have an open mind don't close it off
before it's too late
read the Quran see it for yourself
before you make any assumptions let's
have an open heart and an open mind and
if you really really want to be guided
by God but will guide you so the stocks
for guidance and reoccurrence be with
your neighbors be good to you know your
teachers to everyone just be good to
them this is the essence of Islam when
it comes to rituals these are the few
things you need to remember and
especially clear I'll tell you more
details later on but everyone is waiting
so you just repeat after me how to say a
phrase in Arabic you repeat afternoon I
did not even have a chance oh you speak
English
I was not necessary okay so I will say
it in Arabic word for word and you can
just repeat after me Oh make it very
easy okay repeat after me I mean ongoing
it's roughly going on almost two decades
ha ha ha
ah hoo
now they're pure monotheism is this what
really that what we call Toki the pure
monotheism that drew you into Islam
definitely a shadow muhammadan abduhu wa
rasuluh well now the meaning I bear
witness what was it about Islam that had
you accepted what what was your former
well I'll tell you the truth I was
serving in the US military yeah and I
heard it was when I first deployed to an
Islamic country and I heard the Adhan
called and they send tingles up and down
my spine that there's none worthy of
worship than that there is none worthy
of worship except Allah except Allah
what religion were you a bit before what
I was raised Christian you're back yeah
how about the concept of the love that
we have when you learn about Jesus in
the Quran the first time actually read
surah Maryam it it's touching it makes
you cry because it's like it makes more
sense you know and stuff and you know
Jesus peace be upon him was a prophet
that's dear to me because I never you
know being raised as a Christian I never
believed that Jesus himself was God but
when you don't have something else you
just keep your beliefs so when I you
know found this lump everything made
sense and that's why the transition was
easier for me and I further bear witness
and I further bear witness that Muhammad
Muhammad peace be upon him peace be upon
him is the servant is the servant and
messenger of allah message
congratulation much of it that being so
you were on deployment yeah I was
deployed in military and then you heard
the call to prayer guys yes that Don got
me and then um we had interpreters that
worked for us and one of my interpreters
name was Muhammad we call him Mike play
I caught him Muhammad and the brothers
started as a Dawa with me to teach me
about Islam and
the you know that little seed was
planted and then grew in it you know
eventually he had given me the Shahada
in the back of a Humvee or army truck
but uh I took I retook my Shahada
hearing this master with the brother
that you man my xxx our and that was
2007 where I took the Shahada here but I
had done it properly I made goosal why
did the full body math and I was ready
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
blinkin so long to religion were you
before Christian Christian so what was
it like that so the van and you know we
have like the living miracle tell you
the Quran the life of Prophet Muhammad
what what other things stood out about
Islam but you remember it also
captivated you beyond I mean because you
went up against all odds no I mean yeah
absolutely I'm still going against this
is a jihad is a struggle every day every
day especially living in this country
where people are very oppressive and
prejudiced against Muslims
the fact of the matter is basically when
it was a low-key Allah makes Muslims
Allah chose me right and I knew I was
special from that day on you know people
Christians always try to evangelize and
push it on I'm not here to teach Islam
unless someone wants to be taught I'm
not trying to force anyone to convert
their worries any Muslim so the thing
about Islam is all about the true
tawheed Islamic monotheism there's one
God Allah Allah and there's the mess of
the last messenger Mohammed even even
Abdullah Saleh he was salam may peace be
upon him
yeah
for me thank you very much we were
honored at a hundred in LA to witness a
testimony of someone coming to the Deen
the Shahada bearing witness that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
crater that happens in the earth and
Muhammad just like Jesus Moses Abraham
and all the messages that came peace be
upon him all with that same message
Muhammad is the final messenger
we heard that mashallah he recently
accepted his son but he's been coming to
the classes they are the classes he has
memorized many surah of the Quran and
mashallah his rhythm and everything is
better than a regular amount maybe if
you want to recite just a short sword
ride you see the rhythm and and it gives
who's back with us look at that Ali Cato
car
how you doing brother tell us a little
bit about we were honored to witness
this Shahada tell us a little bit of
what the brother before we meet him
professional fighter and what was talked
about and for a while about their slab
how little witness today all our guide
and open his heart they smell so happy
and I'm very excited coz he'd be my
friend for very long mashallah we're
very excited we learn him in a shade on
your Raji
bismillah tabernacle DVD Hill Mall
Coalition in pas de la vie ha local
motel hey telly below become a oakum
animal Rahul Aziz Allah foo leve Holika
Cerberus emirate in the matter of Iran
many means of forage in the bezel
tomorrow de la basura karate nian called
by Allah kielbasa Posse and voila kaze
be Mesabi how agile Naruto militia T
doesn't want you no more many people
don't know you know many of the
commonalities you know there's so many
misconceptions but how was it when you
learned that Muslims they love Jesus is
one of the mightiest messengers you know
the Quran unchanged tamper key Tambor
proof you know buta the natural way of
only worshiping the crater not the
creation to one God all these things
improve upon proof in the Quran these do
these things fascinate you when you look
going to have I've always since I was in
high school I think or we studied
multiple religions and
I didn't know about Islam yet so my
friend so he's very good teacher to me
so what advice would you have for people
who are you know just brainwashed and
they think Islam is about terrorism and
absolutely radicals what would you say
absolutely not for one the terrorists
are curry tights and and they're
extremists or you taught me very
intrigued with it and I liked I like the
teachings of Islam yeah you know there's
of course some things that are the same
but then others that didn't make sense
and other religions like okay so I just
gravitated towards it yeah a lot of
science that in life that pushed me
towards it too can you give us one so
for the audience and this you know
really encompasses you know the concept
of God chapter 112 in the Quran I had
had a loss ahmed Lemire lead well um you
led
well um yeah colorful and beautiful say
he's going to meet all his brothers from
all over the globe so not only has a
great companion here who shared because
he cared but now how does it also feel
being embraced with so many of your
brothers now in Islam from all different
walks of life it's very interesting it's
new to me
I'm strangers never big family who come
together but it's new and it's very very
loving I didn't say he is Allah who is
one you know Allah the eternal refuge
you know you neither begets a child nor
you know himself is born or not and to
him there is nothing that's equivalent
nothing you can think of you can imagine
breathe speak of draw color anything you
can think of is God every little is
perfect men will ruin anything but the
religion spurns you take care of our
families and the worship Allah and it's
very simple all that other stuff is
wrong we don't kill women and children
we don't commit suicide we don't fight
unless fought and if you punch me in my
mouth and I come to fight you and you
Sam you're sorry peace is peace I won't
do nothing to you because for advice so
you also turn trained martial arts
yes I'm fighting professional fighter
alcohol very nice meeting you and I was
very honored to be able to witness that
today may God Almighty Allah bless you
and continue to bless you
it's Florida here we're here in ah we're
here in Florida and I'm with my Dagestan
me where else from Russia from where
we're we're Thank You Stan we got
Dagestan in the house where we go
Dagestan this is our brother who just
accepted but and we got a leak aitikaf
who you guys fight man who's trying to
stay we're trying to stay out of fight
how you brother's doing when are we
going to die gasping what do you think
we go visit Dagestan our brothers there
got a chain so man this is the beautiful
thing about Islam it is wherever you go
you have Muslims you have people who've
made that conscious decision to connect
with their Creator the one guy all over
the world and we greet each other we're
brothers so the connection is there
we're making a peace be with you
it's deep look into it amazing we're
continuing our trip here in Florida
Salaam alaikum